Marcus Village recently became the
youngest self-made billionaire in the
European Union but for some reason no
one really knows about him he's the
founder of Bolt which is the fastest
growing transportation company in Europe
and Africa whether you need a ride to
the airport in Paris want an electric
scooter in Switzerland or hungry for a
pizza in Romania or are hailing a
motorcycle taxi in Nigeria both has got
you covered the company serves 100
million customers in 45 countries and
was recently valued by investors at over
8 billion dollars but behind this
massive company is the incredible story
of a teenage kid who just wanted to
build something useful and wound up
competing with the largest players in
the transportation industry Marcus was
born in 1993 in Estonia which had
recently gained independence from Russia
Estonia is a very small country and not
exactly the place where Venture
capitalists go to hunt for future
billionaires he grew up on a small
island of just 40 000 people in a
tight-knit community where people leave
their doors unlocked but in 2003 when
Marcus was just 10 years old and Estonia
Was preparing to join the European Union
something unpredictable happen that
would set Estonia on a path to becoming
one of the most technologically advanced
countries in the world that year a group
of Estonian Engineers launched Skype the
first free and easy to use international
voice calling software Skype absolutely
nailed the timing of their launch
Broadband use was growing fast and more
and more laptops were shipping with
built-in microphones Skype was
downloaded over 1 million times within
the first month as consumers around the
world jumped at the chance to stop
paying for expensive international phone
calls in just two years Skype became a
billion dollar business most kids
wouldn't have been aware of the
significance of Skype but Marcus had an
older brother who worked for the company
Marcus had always aspired to be a
scientist when he grew up but seeing his
brother work at Skype Building Products
that impacted millions of people around
the world inspired Marcus to break into
Tech startups so while his peers were
reading comic books 12 year old Marcus
was learning about high-growth tech
companies and new developments in
software engineering by High School
Marcus had learned to code and had a
small business building websites for
local businesses perhaps even more
importantly he started going to a series
of hackathons called garage 48 that his
brother martin was organizing Marcus was
often the youngest person in the room at
those hackathon events but getting out
of his comfort zone paid off because he
got the chance to work with world-class
entrepreneurs like Jan talin founding
engineer of Skype and early investor in
Google's deep mind that's the caliber of
talent that 16 year old Marcus was
surrounding himself with even in the
small Estonian Tech Community Marcus was
able to find the most influential people
and learn from them now none of Marcus's
early hackathon projects gained traction
but he did learn some valuable skills
about building and shipping software
products so in the spring of 2013 as he
prepared to graduate high school Marcus
started bolt a taxi ordering app as
companies achieve success their founding
stories often get turned into myths
which hide the truths about their messy
Beginnings but when you dig deeper you
will often find important details that
can provide lessons for future founders
with Marcus the story of Bolt's early
days is not super straightforward there
was no light bulb moment rather over the
course of six months four separate
events converged to give Marcus the
confidence to start the company first in
search of business ideas Marcus
evaluated a number of Industries and
noticed that Transportation was one of
the largest consumer categories in the
world it's a trillion dollar industry so
there had to be a big opportunity there
second in high school Marcus had written
a research paper about growing
smartphone adoption so he knew that
mobile apps were a future Trend worth
betting on third his brother martin had
told him about a web-based taxi ordering
system that he had used while on a
business trip in Ukraine that system
served as inspiration for the first
version of Bolt and fourth Marcus knew
that there was a problem with the local
taxi industry in Estonia since he had
often experienced subpar taxi service in
his hometown with long wait times and
poor customer service on a busy Friday
or Saturday night Marcus would often
have to spend up to an hour calling all
the local taxi companies trying to find
a ride home and even when he finally did
get a taxi the drivers could be rude
those four factors gave Marcus
confidence that there was a way to
improve things with technology he came
up with the idea for a simple app where
you could see every taxi in a city and
order with just a few Taps he wasn't
trying to build an Uber killer in fact
at the time he didn't even know who Uber
existed in Estonia the taxi Market isn't
as heavily regulated as in places like
Germany or New York so taxi prices were
not the main problem for consumers this
allowed Marcus to work together with the
local taxi companies instead of against
them even though he was optimistic about
the opportunity Marcus started the
company with very limited resources he
might be a billionaire today but in 2013
he was excited just to receive a
scholarship for a hundred euros per
month you can see just how Scrappy his
start was by watching the first promo
video for bolt it looks like Marcus
recorded it in a second-hand furniture
store all things pointed to Marcus not
being able to make the business work but
in 2013 19 year old Marcus wasn't
worried about conquering the world he
just focused on building the best taxi
app for Estonia he concentrated his
limited resources on mastering the three
essential things required to launch a
transportation Network finding Riders
finding drivers and building the app the
first one was easy Marcus had access to
his school email list so he sent out a
Google form survey and got over 600
people to respond most people agreed
that existing taxi services sucked and
joined the waitlist to be notified when
bolt launched signing up drivers was
harder every day after school Marcus
would go visit taxi ranks and try to
convince drivers to sign up getting them
to say yes was extremely difficult the
taxi drivers were resistant to any
technological change most of them didn't
even have a smartphone yet Marcus
probably holds the world record for the
number of taxis that he has been thrown
out of but even though Marcus heard
hundreds of no's he persisted finally
after months of speaking to almost every
taxi driver in Estonia Marcus succeeded
in signing up the first 50 drivers not
as much as he'd hoped for but enough to
gain initial traction the third piece of
the puzzle was technology Marcus
followed the Lean Startup Playbook he
signed up the Riders and drivers before
he actually committed to building the
app even though Marcus was more
technically skilled than 99 of his peers
he still didn't feel like he had the
engineering chops needed to build the
app himself so he borrowed 5000 year
heroes from his parents to hire a
freelance developer 5000 Euros might not
sound like a lot of money especially if
you're from Switzerland or San Francisco
but remember this was 2013 Estonia where
the average salary was only around 700
euros Marcus's parents had been saving
this money for years to help fund his
university studies so when I was trying
to convince my parents to give me the
first couple of thousand Euros to get
going it took me many many weeks to
actually convince them to do it even
though that small investment would be
worth millions in just a few years at
the time it seemed like Marcus had just
flushed his entire college fund down the
drain it took many months for the
freelancer to complete the project and
was finally done Marcus received a
rudimentary app that barely worked he
spent sleepless nights trying to fix the
app himself but he couldn't wait forever
when he wasn't debugging code on stack
Overflow he was still hustling on the
streets trying to sign up more drivers
but entrepreneurs can't wait forever to
reach Perfection so in August of 2013
Marcus launched Bolt's service in its
first city Talon Estonia the summer
before I went to University
we founded the company the start of Bolt
was slow and bumpy only 20 rides a day
at first bolt had absolutely no
marketing budget so Marcus cold called
journalists to get the word out about
the company it's common knowledge that
hiring friends and family members can be
risky but Marcus had to break that rule
instead of hiring a graphic designer he
had his girlfriend design the company's
logo for free oh I just asked her to
help me basically just because we were
thinking that you know I didn't have to
do some designs for him and the logo and
so on and a few months after launch his
older brother martin joined as a
co-founder if you're impressed at the
fact that Marcus started bolt when he
was just 19 years old his brother martin
has an equally impressive track record
when Martin was just 20 years old he
started a technology company took it
public on the local Stock Exchange and
then went through bankruptcy after
the.com bubble all in the span of just a
couple years great things from Thailand
Estonia yes I have been entrepreneur for
about 20 years and we found it all
together with my brother in 2013. but
Bolt's initial prototype was still being
held together by digital duct tape and
Marcus desperately needed someone to fix
the technical debt most Founders would
have promoted a job post on LinkedIn but
Marcus chose a different path you see
most people on LinkedIn generally want
to get paid for their work with money
but Marcus didn't have any money left he
was completely broke so instead Marcus
did what all great entrepreneurs do he
posted the software engineering job ad
on an obscure PHP software developer
upper Forum he got just one response
from an engineer named Oliver was
literally two sentences looking for a
developer a contact email that was it
now Oliver's resume might not look all
that impressive he doesn't have many
LinkedIn connections and instead of
experience at a fancy tech company
Oliver had only worked for a small local
software development agency he designed
an online music store a News website for
a city in Spain as well as a website
that offered to help you increase the
odds of picking winning lottery numbers
now none of these projects are visually
stunning they all scream late 2000's web
design but you should never judge an
introverted software engineer by their
LinkedIn profile as Marcus got to know
Oliver he realized that he was talking
to one of the best developers in Estonia
and made him a co-founder it was the
opportunity of a lifetime and one that
Oliver had been preparing for since he
started coding at the age of eight in a
matter of weeks Oliver built a working
version of the app which put the
company's expansion plans on more solid
ground sound and I got hooked on the
technical aspect of it also it was so
interesting thing to boil because
there's so many different aspects of
building you know this real-time
application none of the founders took a
salary for the first six months and even
later on they continued to operate on a
shoestring budget but their sacrifice
was worth it just eight months in Bolt
had become the local market leader doing
50 000 rides per month and generating 7
000 Euros per month in revenue from taxi
companies but most of the challenges
that both had to overcome still lay
ahead when Marcus tried to raise money
for international expansion no Venture
capitalists wanted to invest in Bolt
because they thought that Uber was going
to dominate the global ride hailing
Market getting turned down by Venture
capitalists is typically a rite of
passage for new entrepreneurs most
investors say no but that doesn't really
matter because it only takes one yes to
get a deal done but in Bolt's case
literally every single brand name
Venture Capital fund that Marcus pitched
turned him down I think there's probably
100 investors in the room who have over
the last six years who all bought into
the idea that Uber is going to be a
monopoly but Marcus is not your typical
19 year old he does not take no for an
answer so instead of shutting the
company down Marcus got creative with
the funding strategy while Uber was
Raising billions of dollars from the
likes of Goldman Sachs and Jeff Bezos
Marcus kept bolt afloat with small
funding rounds from local and unknown
investors early bolt backers included
Finnish angel investor Miko silventola
who made a 4000x return on his 2014
investment and kamos group an Estonian
Forest management company that no
TechCrunch journalist has ever heard of
The Limited funding forced Marcus to
become a master of frugally expanding
into obscure markets others wouldn't
touch this is kind of similar to how Sam
Walton built Walmart into the biggest
retailer in the world by expanding into
small towns where bigger chains didn't
operate for the first couple of years
while Uber was burning billions of
dollars in frustrating Regulators Marcus
flew under the radar expanding his
company in eastern
where competition and regulation was
limited and while Uber had to pay its
Silicon Valley Engineers six-figure
salaries both hired programmers in
Europe where payroll is two to three
times lower engineering we have in three
locations uh Estonia Poland and Romania
this lower overhead meant bolt could
take smaller commissions from drivers
while offering better prices to Riders
whenever the leading payer pushes
margins to be too high starts really
abusing their position with drivers it
actually creates an opening for other
players to come in major ride sharing
companies were charging 30 to 40 percent
commissions from drivers while bolt took
only 15 to 20 percent in some cases we
even take about half the level that our
competition does and why that's even
possible is because from from the start
we've been a very lean company after
building a strong foothold in Eastern
Europe both decided to expand into
another Market ignored by most
competitors Africa this was initially a
counter-intuitive decision we had zero
experience in Africa most of us said
they were never even been there but
Marcus is an extremely data driven
entrepreneur so he ignored conventional
wisdom and focused solely on The
Economic Opportunity and the numbers
didn't lie Africa's high unemployment
made it easy to sign up drivers while
poor public transport created strong
demand for ride sharing things that on
the surface looked like negatives
actually turned into positives for bolt
now one of the key reasons that both has
been successful is that Marcus is
extremely Frugal seriously he never
spends money on anything unless he is
certain that it creates more value for
the customer while American Tech
unicorns were chartering private jets
Marcus didn't want to waste money on an
800 plane ticket to South Africa to plan
his expansion so what did they do well
bolts started in South Africa with just
one local employee who they hired over
Skype from Estonia no one from the
headquarters actually traveled to the
country until almost a year later and
Bolt's first office had none of the
usual Tech startup office perks and when
bolt expanded to other African nations
including Nigeria Ghana Kenya Tanzania
Uganda and Tunisia they always local
lies the product rather than cars Bolt's
most popular category in Africa is
motorcycles both arrived in Africa one
year after Uber so you'd think that
Marcus had no chance of going up against
a much better funded competitor but as
Marcus researched Uber service he
realized the San francisco-based
ride-sharing Behemoth was making
mistakes which bolt was quick to
capitalize on Uber initially only
accepted credit cards even though only a
few percent of Africans actually had
credit cards at the time so bolt offered
locally popular payment methods like
cash payments and mobile carrier billing
and safety is a Hot Topic in Africa so
bolt added an SOS button to its app and
when drivers struggled to get car loans
from Banks it partnered with local
financing companies to help up to 200
000 new drivers get cars and start
driving for bolt today one third of both
businesses in Africa Marcus expanded to
Africa and was able to beat Uber even
though Uber was more than 10 times the
size of Bolt the lesson here is that you
should never be afraid to go up against
bigger companies especially if your name
is Marcus vilig in 2010 Daimler the
parent company of Mercedes-Benz made
what could have been the investment of
the century they paid 50 million dollars
for a 10 stake of an electric vehicle
startup named Tesla Motors today those
shares would be worth 77 billion dollars
unfortunately Daimler decided to sell
their Tesla stake just a few years later
so they missed out on those incredible
returns but the German automotive giant
seems to have learned from its mistakes
with Tesla in 2018 Daimler invested 150
million dollars in Bolt and remains one
of the company's largest shareholders to
this day this German automotive giant
gave up on one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of Our Generation so why
is it betting on a millennial University
Dropout from Estonia who still walks
three miles to work every morning well
Daimler might be the largest
manufacturer of luxury cars in the world
today but looking to the Future it knows
it has a problem today there are about
250 million private cars in Europe and
it's clear that 10 years from now now we
are going to have a lot fewer private
cars than we do today cities are
suffering from traffic congestion and
pollution no politician today is
thinking about how to make car ownership
and driving easier but a lot of
politicians across Europe are working to
make it more difficult they're
increasing fuel taxes introducing low
emission zones and City centers and
promoting public transport Daimler sees
this as a massive risk to their business
so they invested in both as a hedge now
a lot of people think that self-driving
cars are the solution to congestion and
pollution you might remember that Uber
invested billions of dollars into
developing autonomous vehicles a few
years ago but Marcus actually doesn't
believe that the technology will be
ready anytime soon it's not that Marcus
is burying his head in the sand Bolt's
Chief product officer has a PHD in
computer science but for now they are
focusing on the things that work today
not 10 years from now Marcus mentioned
three important things there public
transportation micro Mobility which is
simply an umbrella term for light
Vehicles like bicycles and electric
scooters and shared car
that's why in 2018 bolt entered the
micro Mobility space with the launch of
scooter sharing again it's a bit of an
unexpected move but bolt is already the
largest Micro Mobility company in Europe
it has 130 000 scooters today and is
adding 230 000 more this year one in
four Urban trips is less than two miles
scooters and bicycles can replace a lot
of these short car Journeys I mean even
the president of Estonia swapped out his
motorcade for a bolt scooter but there
are still over 250 million passenger
cars in Europe because of edge cases
like transporting furniture or traveling
to the countryside prevent many people
from giving up their personal cars
Marcus wants to help people give up
their cars entirely so in 2021 bolt
launched bolt drive a short-term car
rental service which allows you to rent
a car with fuel insurance and parking
included for as low as just 12 cents per
minute car sharing is Bolt's most
Capital intensive business which means
bolt can't scale this as fast as its
scooter Fleet for car sharing to become
as convenient as personal cars you need
to have a high density of Vehicles
available at basically every street
corner so every city requires massive
investment but Marcus clearly believes
that despite the high Capital
requirements the business model has
Merit this year bolt plans to expand
bolt drive into nine cities across
Europe one thing is for certain Marcus
isn't slowing down anytime soon remember
transportation is a massive industry
globally so bolt won't run out of growth
opportunities anytime soon Marcus wants
to build bolt into one of the largest
technology companies in Europe this
might sound audacious but Marcus
recently said that he increasingly
believes that the only company that
operates with the same strategy as Bolt
is Amazon both companies enter new
Industries and find ways to make them
significantly more efficient with
technology a lot of companies are good
at technology or operations but bold and
Amazon are good at both I'll leave you
with this in 1998 Amazon was a 600
million dollar Revenue company and its
billionaire founder drove a Honda Civic
to work in 2021 bolt was a 500 million
euro Revenue company and its billionaire
founder walked to work